women are car tester on delayed cinnamon
says he's got a few favorite cars among
them the purest Octavia gt86 the Focus
RS with its drift mode and the powerful
Panamera Turbo S but now he's added one
more to his list the Skoda Octavia RS
Andre says it has a sporty feel lots of
space and a moderate price tag
Scott has turned the RS into a real
racer now of a new RS 232
the outside only minor details give away
the sedan sportiness
like the logos on the outside most
obviously the RS starts with a push of a
button
Andre says the Octavia RS has an output
of 169 kilowatts or 230 horsepower this
doesn't make it a top-notch racer but it
certainly feels like enough power and
when you step on the gas it feels a bit
like you're sitting in an office chair
and someone comes running from behind
and pushes you forward onto I says it's
really good fun nice [ __ ] yet the price
is also not bad in Germany the sedan
will set you back thirty five thousand
two hundred ninety euros for this you
get not only seven kilowatts more power
compared to the standard RS but also an
electronically controlled front axle
inter wheel lock that can distribute the
power to each front wheel as needed with
the DSG dual-clutch transmission the
most powerful Octavia can accelerate
from zero to 100 km/h in 6.8 seconds
Andre would prefer to change gears
manually between curves but the DSG
dual-clutch transmission also has
advantages he says it's more comfortable
when stuck in stop-and-go traffic and
it's also helpful when racing so drivers
can focus entirely on steering and don't
have to think about changing gears Andre
says he's most fond of the sound the
Octavia makes when changing gears and
full throttle DSG doesn't ask abolish
but stay Octavia McNamara for last horse
rides it
Andre reckons the Octavia RS is like a
lovable rogue Skoda has reworked the RS
232 exhaust system the engineers made
sure that it doesn't sound deafening so
the passengers won't go crazy on long
journeys
after all the Octavia RS is designed as
a car for everyday use and not primarily
a racer
well Matisse ladders but Andre thinks
the Octavius seats are a bit of a
problem they're too wide so that you
tend to slide from side to side when you
go around corners he says that reduces
the drivers control somewhat but the
wide seats pay off on longer journeys
and provide extra comfort now it's time
to check out the rear seats pronounced
called Andre is pleased that Skoda
Octavia RS offers so much space in the
back he thinks he could easily spend
long journeys on the backseat even
though he prefers to be in the driver's
seat logos on the interior give away the
Octavius sporty traits many of its
components will be familiar from other
models
the driving mode control lets you adjust
the steering the DSG and the inter wheel
lock so far you can't adjust the
suspension the Octavia has a trunk space
of 590 liters
unfortunately not everything about the
Octavia RS is perfect says Andre the
steering gives very little feedback but
Andre doesn't mind much because the
Octavia has great traction even when
speeding around curves so steering
feedback isn't really that important mr.
Chavez feedback garnish VRS to 30 is
SCOTUS attempt to beef up the Octavia RS
using successful VW technology but was
that worth the effort
after all the Octavia RS has already
been a big success
dr. Condry says the question remains if
the rs232 thousand euros that depends if
drivers regularly hit the racetrack here
the electronically controlled front axle
inter wheel walk really pays off as it
provides better grip on bends but Andrei
thinks for most people the normal RS
will suffice